We've built a Universe Matrix, and we did
it without Keanu.
It's everything astronomical scientists could
ever want.
Which has led them, inexorably, here.
Howdy y'all, Trace here for DNews with your
weekly space update!
We've done it!
We've created a computer simulated universe
using 13 billion years, 41,000 galaxies, 350
million light-years wide -- this simulation
is the largest most accurate EVER and ... what
is it for again?
Scientists have gathered reams of information
on our universe over the last few centuries,
how it moves, interconnects, reacts, grows
and changes.
We have theories about how it was formed,
how parts of it die, and how things behave!
But they're scattered through tons of books,
papers and human brains.
This stimulated universe, called "Illustris,"
is a way to put ALL these theories in one
place and run experiments to check if these
vast hypotheses are correct.
This is like a SimUniverse game... the researchers
can go forward or backward in time, from 12
million years after The Big Bang, all the
way to what we can see today.
As time flies in the simulation, scientists
can track the formation of galaxies and follow
how we think the universe came to be.
This has been REALLY tough to create before
now because our understanding of dark energy
and dark matter is a HUGE variable.
That dark stuff makes up 95% of the universe,
so getting it right in the simulation without
ever directly observing it is pretty tough,
but the guys at MIT where the simulation lives
are confident.
The best part about this simulation is the
tracking of the big stuff, like spiral and
elliptical galaxies, and small stuff like
protons, electrons and neutrons.
Seriously, that's all in there.
It takes a supercomputer to run it.
It uses 8,192 CPUs to render the graphics
for the simulator and it took six months to
chug through all 13 billion years.
All this aside, these scientists aren't perfect,
and they know their amazing computer program
isn't perfect either, but it's a huge step
toward understanding how galaxies form and
interact.
Each particle of gas in the simulator is 1
MILLION SOLAR MASSES -- like one million suns.
Like early digital cameras, it's tough to
pick up ALL the details when you take a picture
-- but that doesn't mean you can't see the
image.
Scientists are already finding things wrong
and calling them out, because science -- we're
not afraid to be wrong.
This lil SimUniverse doesn't form low-mass
galaxy stars at the right time and they can't
model massive galaxy clusters -- but that's
due to minimum computer requirements.
Dammit.
Time to get a new graphics card... or 8,129
of them.
If you had eight thousands computers what
kind of science would you want to simulate?
Tell us in the comments and make sure you
subscribe so you don't miss a DNews.
Two episodes, every day!
For more space stuff check out DiscoveryNews.com
and watch more DNews.
You can connect with us on Twitter, Facebook
and everywhere else!
See ya!